hey what's going on YouTube you like the
new setup it's actually not a new setup
I'm back at home here to relax and do
some work and some loud grandmother
clapping but I wanted to go ahead and
talk to you guys about something real
quick now you guys know me I'm a pretty
Pleasant guy I mean oh - the occasional
wrench the cursing the yelling the
fighting a yoo-hoo but recently I was at
the Best Buy and I got approached by
somebody who had a very very negative
and pissed-off
attitude now you guys don't want to come
to the shopping experience you don't
want to receive any type of negativity
you want to go in buy a [ __ ] get greeted
say bye move on about your day but
sometimes when you go to these places
there are people that hate that [ __ ]
job and what I mean by these type of
people are the people that hate their
job so much that they express their
negativity on - yeah you was looking for
[ __ ] [ __ ] here now now today I was
at the best fight - go ahead and pick up
one of these bad boys uhd ponder what
but right when I was leave with the door
there was his doing this bright yellow
best boxer he comes up to me he says hey
could we [ __ ] wars in the air now it
was his job to go ahead and check the
receipt to see that I wasn't stealing
anything perfectly fine problem was was
the way that he approached me his
attitude the way he was talking to me
and the look and his [ __ ] eyes
what job stupid ass yellow shirt looking
like a broke-ass superhero called the
yellow mistake now as I paused that I
listed the guy I was like you know what
this isn't worth it now for me it's not
worth it and let me explain why I feel
bad for the [ __ ] because in
order for somebody to treat you like
that probably on a regular basis that
person wakes up every day hating their
[ __ ] job I don't know what that feels
like because I love what I'm doing even
though I only get a couple hours of
sleep I'm going seven days a [ __ ]
week I wake up happy because I love what
I'm doing and not a lot of people had
that he wakes up knowing that he's going
to a job that he [ __ ] hates and
because of his negativity that he feels
towards himself he projects it on other
people now for me I can go up complain
to management I could have walked into
his face and said something like you
know what [ __ ] come outside I'm a
pepper spray you but I'm not gonna do
that because I left my pepper spray in
the car because life has already gotten
him now I'm not saying sir that you are
gonna be that type of person for the
rest of your life you might get your
[ __ ] together you might get a better job
but the problem with you once again is
that you sir feeling tight meaning
you feel like you don't deserve that job
because you feel like you deserve better
but i'ma tell you something right now
your attitude doesn't prove for me you
guys already know I grew up [ __ ] broke
before I started doing YouTube straight
up I was working three [ __ ] jobs no
the full-time students still trying to
be a stand-up comedian so you tell me
how [ __ ] hard was that did I wake up
every day hating myself a little bit cuz
I was kind of fed on the [ __ ] side but
that's more of like a self-esteem issue
like I'll go to the beach and then
people will be like oh my god why is
that snowman not melting but what I'm
saying is people out there if you ever
meet somebody like that when they come
up to you and they're mad aggressive and
they're super rude to you
guess what they probably hate their life
shake their head and say you know what
[ __ ] I feel sorry for you follow the
few years younger and a lot more dumb I
woulda came up to him super
confrontation on the back to [ __ ] off
and chill off his attitude but what does
that do it doesn't do anything doesn't
solve a situation is not gonna make him
a better person it might get him fired
and already he hates his life so what am
i doing for the guy PS